two more American troops have been
killed in Afghanistan the military said
they died in a fire fight but did not
give any more details their deaths come
as the US continues peace talks with the
Taliban in Qatar MTS ty Abbey is in Doha
where he got rare access to Taliban
negotiators empty as good morning good
morning well in a rare interview with
the Taliban's
top spokesman he insists the group wants
peace even as two American soldiers are
killed overnight in Afghanistan this
year alone 14 US servicemen have lost
their lives on the Afghan battlefield
already more than all of last year
Taliban spokesman Sohail Shaheen says
the ongoing bloodshed should focus our
minds of negotiators when two US
soldiers died on the eve of those talks
certainly that has an impact on how you
move forward oh yes I think it should
have a positive impact
yes that it is very Sicily put an end to
the war but distrust between the Taliban
and the american-backed Afghan
government may prove to be a far bigger
battle the Taliban is accusing political
leaders in Kabul of supporting Isis who
bombed this wedding over the weekend
killing 80
this is elements within the current
Afghan government or supporting Isis in
Afghanistan that did to destabilize any
kind of agreement it's a very serious
this is yes it is an open secret
everyone know about that a stunning
allegation against an American partner
even more stunning with Sheheen's
refusal to accept al-qaeda's
responsibility for the September 11th
attacks who still it is not known who
was behind if there is a proof
given to us we are ready to try him
Naboth Taliban and US negotiators say
they want a deal to end America's
longest war but with so much distrust
between the Taliban and other Afghans
charting the country's political future
together won't be easy
Anthony MTS taya Ben cutter thank you